vamos a buscar el límite en esta ocasión
de 6x cuadrada más 5 x 1 cuando x tienda
menos 1 ahora la primera cosa que
seguramente te va a llamar la atención
es que esta expresión define una gráfica
de una parábola que se vería más o menos
así y aunque no estoy haciendo la prueba
rigurosa por aquí podemos decir que es
una parábola que abre hacia arriba y la
gráfica como puedes ver es una función
continua es decir no tenemos ninguna
discontinuidad o salto o algún hueco de
hecho en general cualquier función
cuadrática como la que tenemos aquí está
definida para cualquier valor de x es
decir está definida para todos los
números reales y eso quiere decir que es
una función continua así que ha sido una
función es continua para todos los
números reales entonces el límite de
esta expresión cuando x se aproxima a
uno de estos valores reales va a ser
simplemente la evaluación de la función
en ese valor
es decir estoy diciendo que una función
es continua en x igual a am si y sólo si
el límite cuando x tiende a amd fx es
igual a efe de a así que bueno aunque no
estoy haciendo una prueba rigurosa
conceptualmente creo que se entiende
bastante bien así que si aquí tenemos
una función cuadrática estándar definida
para todos los números reales por lo
tanto es continua para todos los números
reales eso significa que tenemos esta
parte de aquí las funciones continúan en
x igual a menos 1 y entonces el límite
de fx cuando x tiende a menos 1 va a ser
simplemente efe de menos uno
entonces a vale menos uno así que
evaluaremos la función en menos 1 me va
a quedar 6 que multiplica a menos 1
elevado al cuadrado más 5 veces menos
uno menos uno y bueno menos uno al
cuadrado es
5 - 1 es lo mismo que menos 5 y entonces
tengo 65 menos 1
eso es simplemente cero y ya con esto
hemos acabado